谢谢大家
这两天市场波动非常大
不过大家可能就是很期待知道一下怎么回事
其实我先放一张Decons的图
City of True Tales
美国和中国现在我觉得感觉非常像双层级
上一周其实包括周末的时候
我们有很多的对冲基金的discussion
包括闭门的会议
其实大家讨论的主要的两个点就是美国现在是不是到底
宏观上怎么看
然后
三个问题
这是一个
第二个是AI是不是个泡沫
这个泡沫如果是的话那么怎么去判断它
会不会到这个泡沫什么时候有可能会破
然后第三呢中国现在是不是到底
你们是不是我们觉得美国这个机会不好以后
中国会有很大机会特别是这个deep seek
和我们现在要开这个两会然后有一些硬的政策
然后包括我们看到中国的很多数据也在变好
那么结合这三个事情其实我觉得我们上一周有很多很多discussion
那个特别在香港这个对冲基金的圈子里面
我觉得我先说一下我的看法吧
中国和美国两个像软身的就是双层级里面
两个软身的城市像像那个纽约和巴黎一样
就说好像是一个coin一个硬币的两面
就说美国以前是需求带动中国的supply中国的供应
那么中美关系变差了以后其实美国又发生了通胀
然后中国又发生了通缩
那就没有这么简单但本质上这两个国家走的方向
就美国在印钱
那中国的通缩印钱没有用
接着呢过去三年里面美国通胀被控制住经济增长
还就非常不错
然后特别是AI和科技在带动
中国的科技是看上去因为政策打压基本上全部歇菜
那么歇菜的时候中国变成一个红利社会
谁能够制造
然后成本地卷得多
然后就红利社会
那么其实Deep Seed发生出现了以后
有很多人改变了这看法
觉得中国科技或者是中国科技股也应该有一席之地
那么特别是美国最近在调整
我们看到特朗普上台之后
美国调整还是比较严重了
就特别是我们昨天看到关税的事情有很大的调整
那么这个立场是不是沉溺
首先我觉得肯定是不沉溺
包括我对Deep Seed的看法
Deep Seed它有
你可以说它20%是工程化的改造
但是它有80%是结果推
就结果推过程
它其实拿了很多OpenAI的训练结果
你两个模型去比较的话
其实有一个比较模型
等于有一个训练模型
它的比较模型有可能直接用的是OpenAI
或者是用了其他的AI的平台
所以我觉得这个技术上肯定不存在这个过程
也就是说
但是市场有很多这样的讨论
也让整个市场
就是整个我们看到空关市场上有这种讨论
所以港股你看到最近党内有很多
那么现在又有一个flip
我们说it was the best of time
it is the worst of time
美国确实是在最好时候
也是在最差的时候
那么我们看到
就是与中国过去
可能有一个很多虎逼的政策
这个这个次用的有点过分
但是中国从2013年14年之后
很多的政策其实
我们认为它是挺莽撞
那么美国现在有个很虎逼的总统
就出了很多奇怪的政策
所以我们看到这个过程里面
就是去怎么评判这个空关
不好意思
您稍等一下下
我给你合作
那个所以这个呢
我觉得是一个市场的
就是一个很观点
首先我是觉得在那个
我们看一下美国的经济数据
就是我们看到上周以来
美国的经济数据
其实一直在增长上
在突破这个预期
往下突破预期
也就是说我们之前一直预测的
美国2025年经济增长比较稳定
通胀就basicase上经济增长比较稳定
然后通胀上的那个主步变小
是不考虑到美国的这个特朗普的政策的
我们看到特朗普很明显的政策
tariff
现在immigration
我们看到他移民政策还没出来
看到他比较说tariff的政策
一定会导致美国2025年经济增长
会弱于预期
有人觉得特朗普有两方面的政策
就是一方面他有tariff
有那个关税
另外一方面他有basicase
就是我们叫做这个税收减税
减税很多人是预期减税
能够给美国带来一些增长
那么tariff关税有可能会美国带来负面的影响
但是其实我在去年年底时候也说过这个问题
年初收一直在重生
为什么要降仓
为什么要违避这个风险
就是这个风险在于
所有他政策产生的负面影响
都是在眼前发生的
但是他的政策产生的证明的影响
也要等到2026年才产生
所以总结来说
2025年可能会是相对来说比较偏差
就是经济上可能会偏差
甚至极端情况下可能会发生衰退
那么在2026年的话
如果他tax cut实际发生的话
那么有可能会就是反过来给到美国一个助力
所以2025年和2026年的大概的交易的
这个头寸呢
其实2025年一定要归避风险
那么我们看到上周的几个数据
就是说很多人破了load of effort
很多人很关注这个ISM的manufacturing PMI
美国PMI接近50容忽点了
那么就说中国的PMI跑过50以上了
包括我们看到中国的房地产在反弹
中国房地产在1月份2月份的时候
有很多的这个成交量在上升
那这个是这一年以来
为一年以来一个比较meaniful的上升
那么同时的话呢
按照就是中国房地产中间40%的那个
二手房是占40%
所以房地产在交易量在恢复
就是价钱没有恢复
交易量在恢复
二手房交易量也在恢复
那么那个PMI再上升
那么美国的PMI再下降
那么是不是东升西降
这这个是香港很多对冲基金
一直在谈的这个问题最近
那么首先呢
我觉得美国的PMI对于美国经济的影响不算大
包括那个ISM和PMI影响都不是特别大
那么为什么
因为私营部门对于整个经济的影响一大半
但是另外一半呢是国家的影响
所以美国过去几年
你可以看到这些先行指数
包括PMI
包括consumer index
consumer confidence index
这不是非常重要
但是这个数据也不太好
consumer confidence index
就是那个消费信息指数
这个更多的代表的是
私营部门的一个
forward locking往前看的状态
当你利率很高的时候
这些数据不好很正常
但是问题是呢
过去几年有一个政府在那里一直在消费
也就是说
总的信贷里面
私营部门1%到20%增长
政府10%的增长
那么平均一下5%
这就是美国过去一直不会衰退
包括我们去年说
美国任务会不会衰退
只要不动摇这个
它就不会衰赔
但是今年DOG可能会动摇这个东西
所以这个PMI和ISM再出现的话
有可能就是面对的
就是说
未来几个月经济可能会下行
包括你看到那个concini
就是PCE
PCE是2.6
那2.6这个PCE相对来说
是相对来说
比上一个平台在2.8左右的这个平台
是往下跑的
也就是说我们看到
美国整体的经济的状态是
通胀开始往下跑
然后经济开始
经济的先进指数已经开始变差
就业指数
我们说主要的就业指数
比方说能放配肉
还没有变差
但是Initial Jobless Claim
这个首次申请世界竞人数
这个还没有包括DOG
采药那些人
已经超过预期了
所以现在市场开始定价
美国有没有可能开始有衰退的迹象
但是我觉得市场投存
还没有累积到
大家认为它会衰退
所以这个预期完全没有打满
就是在这个状况下
就是特朗普的政策
和后面他采取的这个政策
包括他退税
包括他关税
这些东西又会变得尤为重要
因为你可以想
我给你看一个关税的图案
我们现在说的是我们预期
这个预期的话
有可能关税加到比较税
Effective的就实际的关税加到4%
那么这个对PCE影响
对于通胀影响
大概除以10
就是明日0.5到0.4到0.5
相反对于GDP影响是反过来的
大概0.5
所以这个影响你还是可以忍受的
那么在昨天的时候
他说要给墨西哥不延期了
墨西哥加拿大不延期了
那么这两个加上去
那就太能够来说了
可以看这个数字
25%加拿大在这里
25%墨西哥
那么这个数量已经是远远超过
现在这个就是对于中国实际加的税
包括对于中国前面版本
就是后面版本是加在一起
这个影响还挤不上
就是25%墨西哥
但墨西哥中间有很多是中国
中国掌口贸易
所以Tariff对整个经济的影响
就是特别是你们想
为什么墨西哥加拿大
墨西哥加拿大是他第一第二的
贸易伙伴
中国墨西哥加拿大前三
我忘了这个中国有没有反超
那么前三
所以你直接给前三中间的
每个人加25%
那么对于经济来说
一定是一个极大负面
所以你昨天看到的市场已经告诉了
特朗普
股票要跌
然后债券
才是债券要升
就是债息在跌
债债在跌债券在升
然后美元再变质
那也就是意味着
就是你的政策是不能够实施的
这个是市场告诉美国的
但是他最后会采取什么样措施呢
我个人觉得墨西哥和加拿大是不会加的
就是这两块是不会加上去
如果加上去
那么就是市场今天跌了
昨天跌了1.50%
那么但是每一次
第一次说加中国10%
墨西哥加拿大25%
那中国实施
实施在待给加上去
然后墨西哥加拿大25%
中国再加10%
这个10%又被实施再加上去了
所以我觉得非常有可能的真正实施的
就是在左边的这些水收政策
就是critical import tax
加上可能后面会给欧洲去加税
然后但是这些
比方说加拿大和墨西哥
包括 reciprocal tariff
那些东西
我觉得不一定会加上去
所以这个是
当然了
现在川普的政策
会变得越来越不确定了
但是他包括他昨天
我们当会讲到
他在币圈的一些行为
包括他和Zelensky的之间的
和乌克兰之间的这些矛盾
所以这些事情
我觉得使得整个市场
不确定性会大很多
那么讲一下
那个特朗普政策
可能会给市场带来的正面的事情
就首先就给市场带来正面
这个事情在2025
主要是在退税上的tascut
也就是说2025年时候
他大概有相当于三分之一级dp
也就是4000亿美元的tascut
这个东西是特朗普上一届的
上一届的一个延续
就是在拜登时代一直在被延续下来
这个大概就会延续下去
但是这个对市场
不造成增量的影响
那么接下去
他可能会有
根据他的budget提供了
这个budget给议会的budget
是希望10年里面
每年降450个别岭
就是降450个别岭
每年降
但是有可能真正的能够一开始实施
因为这个是口号
10年是一样的
真正能够实施的是一开始
大概今年
今年会发出来大概100个别岭的课
这100个别岭课
什么时候出来
11月份
所以你即使有tax cut的影响
也是后面慢慢发生的
但是他的spilling cut
他的这个花费的降低
他预期是150个别岭每年
那我觉得他今年有可能会cut到150个别岭
所以就是相当于
政府的支出变少了
原来政府支出每年还在增加的
增量的
那现在开始变得少了
然后接下去
几个时间点也比较重要
比方说3月14号
有一个potential government shutdown
这件事情
他就算是应该是大咖喱能够被解决
然后他的这个deal
tax cut deal到4月份的时候提交参众两院
然后可能就是legislation到7月底
所以在这个中间中间
在这个事情中间的每个点
都有可能是个爆发点
就像我们上次讲到
那个第一次说给加拿大和墨西哥加税
然后他其实谈判的目标
是希望加拿大比方说墨西哥
他希望墨西哥给中国一起加税
然后中国转口他也要加税
那这样的话
其实最终的他对的
大家都知道最终对的出口
就是对中国的出口
他不是对其他人
所以每次给中国加将去不会减
其他地方的
你要跟着美国的税制一起走
所以一起要对中国加税
包括这个事情
其实包括上次我们讲到他
他在最后达成协议之前
可能肯定会意识发展出赴
所以你看到这次又反复了
那明天就开始加税了
但是加了税不代表他不会去掉
他也可以跟你谈判谈好
之后就把他弄掉
我觉得这也很有可能
所以我觉得大概率的情况下
还是就是左边这些可控的这些税
对于今年的整体经济影响
我觉得他互0.5
对于那个通脏影响
正0.5
所以整个市场就是
我觉得在一个basicase
即使在一个basicase情况下
不太存在大涨
但是在如果才去比较激进的政策的话
这些右边任何一个税出了
我觉得都是一个比较激进的政策
如果采取一个比较激进的政策的话
那么这个市场就是要面临一个比较大的调整
因为现在市场毕竟没有pricing
美国可能会衰退
或者是美国任何真正衰退的问题
都没有pricing
那么什么时候有可能会是个机会
就说这个事情是不是
就说我们现在在做spanning cut
在做DOG
是不是这个是一个long run
就长期的看好的事情
我其实持相对比较正面的意见
对于美国
因为你这个东西就我上次讲的
你就是在海归身上去腾湖吗
你在海归身上去腾湖短期的正统之后
那么有更多的钱会到了私营部门
更多的就是我们社会资源
会到私营部门
其实这个对社会长期一定是利好的
对于你的txt cut当你今年年底
100个billion出来
明年可能还会有
那么这些txt cut在这几年里面
如果是能够按照计划实施的话
对于美国经济的长期肯定是利好的
所以我们说tell to city
中国和美国相反
美国长期是继续非常的很好
就是即使特朗普瞎搞
这政策上有一些影响
哪怕他把美国搞成衰退了
那么这个衰退也是给你一个入场的机会
那中国的事情
我们上周也其实已经讲过了
这周补充些信息吧
包括我们看到房地产数据在反弹
包括我们现在看到中国投资的机会
从IDC的硬件
开始慢慢转到政府采购的软件
AI的软件
包括dpsc
可让很多软件的这个下限变低了
那么包括我们看到很多南下资金
包括港股在过去三个月里面
有很多南下资金中间补
不少于很多的保险资金
包括在配置
甚至有很多听说
央行的资金也在做配置
那么接下去几天
要看人大
那么有可能会有政策推出
所以这一系列的利好
把整个港股市场
包括A股市场在网上推动
那我为什么对这个事情
还是比较
呃比较悲观
因为我们当
我们很多人用到一个词
就是注底
那我觉得不是注底
是反弹
反弹的过程比注底开心
因为它是往上跑
但是反弹的结果比注底要惨
因为它是一个无尽的声援
继续跌下去
那中国的问题
就是在于我们之前一直讲的
就是它通缩的三座大山
翻不过去
那个人口它解决不了
那么第二个
就是过渡过度的产能
在美国的这个加税下面
它对中国的税是
有老实的权跟你加上去
所以在美国的中国的
包括它现在要围堵
加拿大、墨西哥
或者是欧门
它后面可能围堵欧门
就是对于所有中国出口产品
就要给你加税
所以这一些政策下面
我们过渡的产能是很难消化掉的
在1月份、2月份为什么好呢
首先9月份开始中国印钱
国债在印钱
第二呢
有很多存货的原因
大家知道
特朗普可能要出那个贸易的政策
那美国方面在做存货
所以外贸数据也会变得更好
但是真正的这个关税
加上去以后
假以时过几个月之后
那么在真正实施的以后
那么这个贸易的数据
可以很有可能会往下跑
中国去年GDP归因
大概有一半是靠外贸
主要是靠美国的需求
不管你贸易的哪个国家
最后都是美国的需求
所以你就说
这是双成绩
你其实是靠人家美需在过日子的
你还天天喊着反美
你靠着这个美需在过日子
你50%的GDP归因
去年的增长的归因
可能是归在外贸上面
那么这个东西加了20%关税
你是非常难过的
第二就是
第三就是
人大不管住什么安分
我觉得主要是两部分
第一部分是化债
化债并不是说
你有可能是政府印的钱
或者是政府加大动感
然后让你的债能够化掉
能够解决掉
能够往后
但是对于整个经济的政策
我们不是在解决资产负代表
我们是在希望加更高的杠杆
包括给私营部门加更高的杠杆
但是私营部门的资产负代表
已经不太支持能够加更高的杠杆
这个我们观点
我们之前讲过好多次
所以我是觉得
东深西降的可能是很小的
今年确实是一个反弹
而且我们从去年开始
就觉得今年会反弹
毕竟看空我一看空了三年
从疫情到现在
我几乎每天都打反弹
那个去年我们就说
可能会有个半年级别的反弹
但去年没有发生
那么政策改变之后
今年发生
我觉得是有可能的
但是这个一定是一个反弹
它不是注底
它往下是没有
往下通道是没有阻力的
就是你每次反弹之后还是要往下
本质场是中国的没有消费
就是没有资产
没有人口也是没有消费
没有美须也是没有消费
然后资产赋料比较破损
那个老板就没钱
说实话也是没有消费
所以这个没有消费是很难
就是很难被解决的
那么同时的话
我不觉得美国特朗普做的这个事情
在短期里面
能够让美国经济过得很好
因为他要做的是供应测改革
所有人做供应测改革
和基本上都会失败
他在做供应测改革
特朗普在做供应测改革的同时
他在做需求测改革
他把需求再减少
一旦需求减少
影响最大的一定是最大的供应方
就是说你在减少需求的时候
没有办法把供应提上去的
所以美国的制造也恢复可以吗
很难
但是你把需求减少的时候
谁吃的苦最大
中国
所以他其实说穿了
就是我觉得这一次很有可能是
特朗普下桌
然后最后是中国买单
那么现在Deep Seek带动了中国
很多软件
然后高科技这些投资
有没有机会
我觉得几个月可能是有的
但是你要知道
他把港股打开
包括现在A在H很容易的批准
对吧
然后希望在港股上面
很多的资金
包括港股固执地码
很多中国的保险资金
养好资金
把港股炒热
其实本质上
他还是想去融资
他想去化债的
中国在后面一段时间
整个债务的问题
外贸的问题
和经济的问题
基本面影响还是很大
也就是我们上次讲到的
中国TMT公司时长增加这么多
它的UP值
就是它的每个客户的盈利
一直在减小
它的盈利能力在红光下面
是没有办法恢复的
这是中国真正的一个印象
所以我对中国的整个市场
就是我觉得这轮反弹可能会有
但是很难动身细脚
有可能是
我一个朋友讲的就很经典的话
他说是很有可能牺牲东不深
这个是有可能的
或者是牺不深
就东臂脚
这都有可能
但是东身细脚是绝对没有巡向
这个是非常困难
然后说一下AI的问题
比如说AI的泡沫问题
其实AI泡沫
也是最近讨论很多的一个事情
我觉得是这样
AI的泡沫最后
因为现在的所有的
AI的整体的行业促进的
行业的股票市场上来看的话
主要就是Navillion 英伟达
因为大量的投资
触动了英伟达的股价
然后前面的广告商是OpenAI
只是DeepSeq出来的
把这个广告商给砸坏了
你说你做的这个广告好像很厉害
就是你需要这么大机群
十亿级别的机群的训练
我可能不需要
那么大家搞不清楚Navillion应该怎么估了
最后的Typex怎么放
他也不知道
包括最近在网上传播很多
就是Covas的简单
那这个事情我补充一下
就Covas的降单这件事情
因为这很正常
因为年初的时候
大家都要报更多
然后才能够报更多
然后才能够拿到这些Covas的现成
那么在现在这个时候
就是办上去把Covas剪了
其实它的真正的需求
或者大家对于Earning的
预估Earning的
就每个公司预估自己
这个盈利的时候
用的这个数据
其实没有影响
也就是说今年的Covas
包括今年的Typex
整个市场的投入
我觉得没有影响
所以当然市场会对
这个这些信息做出反应
但是其实盈利
公司的业绩
不太会有反应
那么最大的问题还是在明年
就是明年要继续这个云厂
继续这样的投入
然后因为它的业绩
继续这样的增加
那么本质上 AI
需要有能力段的突破
什么叫能力段的突破
就是它的增量
能够带来GDP上升
就是效率的增加带来GDP上升
那么这个东西能看到吗
不是投入带来的
是它减效带来的
那么现在这个事情能看到吗
必定能看到
但是今年肯定看不到
所以你说 AI有没有泡沫
在今年一定是有泡沫的
在那个长期来看
可能是没有泡沫
所以你现在来说
在 AI 上的投入
我觉得最快哪些方面
能够跑出真正的提高效率
就是它总要能做一件
你以前不能做的事情
解决你以前不能解决的问题
那么 AI
第一步能够做得到
解决不能解决问题
就是它防务上面
那么防务上面
我补充说一个防务的东西
那就说到
贼文司机和特朗普的这个矛盾
这个新闻大家应该都看得到
就是上桌应该都看到过这个事情
那么这个矛盾
其实本质上最后的结果是
非常有可能是
欧洲会增加房务的投入
然后美国房务投入不会改变
欧洲会增加房务投入
贼文司机不一定会投降的
所以 AI 泡沫
它最后能够影响的是什么东西
我觉得很有可能影响比较大的
就是一个是房务
一个是医疗
然后是交通
所以这个一定是最先跑出来
包括 FSD
这些东西是最先跑出来
能带来效率提升的
那么这些比较快的
比方说房务现在已经可以了
军事上已经可以使用
那么但是医疗上交通上的使用
那我看至少到明年
包括 RoboTaxin
包括六月份推出你就比较顺利的话
也要到明年才有可能
所以你说今年的 AI 能不能带来
泡沫
是不是有泡沫
肯定是有的
那么配合特朗普的这些政策
那我觉得今年大家保持低一点
那么防范一下这个维步的风险
当然了
他也有可能走 Base Case
就是这些东西都是花花长子
包括 Tariff
包括简持字
他都是花花长子
经济增长继续继续维持
那么NAS大厕就应该比较说
两个百分之五到十
从今年年初到现在
从今年年初到后面
长个百分之五到十
那我觉得还是一个延续性的牛市
但是你的检仓不会让你少赚多少钱了
就是这个市场并不像去年和前年这样的风有
好
然后最后提一下币圈
大家比较感兴趣的一件事情
特朗普说
因为我准备的时候是昨天前天
然后我本来想说大家
他既然没敢在白宫去发布
我要做比特币的区块链的储备
这个事情你可以认为
他是准备做老祖堂
或者是他的团队
这个就是跟操作特朗普币的团队
是一波团队
他就割剥韭菜
所以大家如果要信就尽早信
然后尽早走
但是我看昨天好像市场已经跌下去
那么你们就我觉得可以等那个
呃
其实我觉得没有什么可信的
就这种东西他
他如果真的要干的话
他就通过那个
他肯定是通过那个
那个白宫去发行
而不是通过自己一个
甚至不再推特的账号
发在自己的那个
什么出搜缩那个迷遍省
所以就是
我觉得对避圈来说
一定是一个很大的利空
因为他割掉的每一分钱
都是避圈的钱
就是这个池子里有多少鱼
有多少水
就是就这点
他割掉一个亿
那就少一个亿
所以肯定是个长期来说
肯定是个利空了
那么但是呃短期的反弹会到
每就是反弹是不是终止
最后反弹会在哪里
太好讲
那个如果没有走掉的话
你可以等他星期五的那个会
再看一看
但是我我我我
我个人是比较偏非观一点
好吧
那个我今天先讲到这里
然后看看大家有些什么问题